[Music]
foreign
welcome to the NewsHour we begin in
Japan that's where G7 leaders are
meeting in Hiroshima the group has
agreed new sanctions they say quote star
of Russia of G7 technology industrial
equipment and services that support its
War Machine let's go live to Hiroshima
and speak to Rob McBride so Ukraine the
war in Ukraine is top of that agenda
Robin there's some confusion over
whether president zielinski will be
attending in person or not what more do
we know
thank you
that's right uh the opening day of this
G7 and the agenda being dominated as
expected by the war in Ukraine but the
one world leader who's actually been
making all the headlines on this first
day is not actually here that's Vladimir
zelenski of Ukraine because there has
been swirling speculation since the very
start of this day that he would actually
be attending in person on the last day
that would be on Sunday it was
originally anticipated that he was only
going to be making a video address via a
remote connection but then it was widely
reported very early on that he would
actually be making the journey to attend
in person to press the case for more
support for his country not only amongst
the G7 members who are widely committed
to supporting uh Ukraine but also
amongst many other world leaders who've
been invited here as guests especially
world leaders from non-aligned Nations
or neutral Nations so it was seen as a
very significant develop equipment then
much later in the day reports from
Ukraine itself seem to indicate that it
is back to the original plan of just a
remote appearance via video link we are
hearing from the Ukraine's security and
National Defense Council that that it
will be the case he will not actually be
making the journey here he will be
addressing by a video link nonetheless
there has still been uh the agenda's
been dominated a lot of the discussions
uh have been dominated by the Ukraine
war and also support for Ukraine and
condemnation for Russia the new
sanctions have been announced also new
measures to prevent Moscow from getting
round some of those sanctions and also
they have G7 members have issued a
lengthy statement outlining their
position there isn't anything
particularly new there it is a repeat of
the condemnation of Russia support for
Ukraine but interestingly there is one
passage there that calls for the
complete complete unconditional
withdrawal of Russian troops and
equipment and that that should be a
precondition and must be included
according to this statement in any cause
for peace now that would seem to be a
sideways swipe at China because it's
much vaunted peace proposal outlined a
few months ago a cause for an immediate
ceasefire all well and good but without
calling demanding that Russia gives up
or any of the territory that it has
taken illegally effectively freezing the
front lines in place which is not
acceptable to Ukraine by association not
acceptable to its Western supporters
right and Rob let me ask you about the
significance of the location because how
significant is it at the Summit is being
held in Hiroshima
foreign
this was a hugely symbolic day at the G7
members with the Japanese hosts attended
the Hiroshima Peace Park which it
commemorates the attack 70 80 years ago
that had effectively destroyed the whole
of Hiroshima especially in significant
for fumio kashida the Japanese prime
minister he is an MP from from this city
he wanted to show his G7 Partners just
the evils of nuclear attacks it has to
be noted that three of the G7 partners
are members of the original nuclear Club
if you like France the UK and the US and
kashida has called for all countries
despite the rise intentions the rising
conflicts around the world to give up at
some point their nuclear weapons okay
thank you that's Rob McBride reporting
for us from the G7 Summit currently
taking place in Japan we can also speak
to Tristan Naylor who's the deputy
director of the the G7 and G20 research
groups he's also an assistant professor
of history and politics at Cambridge
University and you're joining us as well
from Hiroshima good to have you with us
thanks for speaking us so Rob was just
mentioning that much of the rhetoric is
sort of leading up to the summit and at
the summit has been on these newly
announced sanctions on Russia as well as
the war in Ukraine will be dominating
that agenda how important is it for
these leaders to be putting on a United
front when it comes to Ukraine
it's of supreme importance it's exactly
what the G7 did when they met last year
in Germany uh of Chief importance was
communicating that they were United that
a wedge could not be driven between them
despite having some differences with
respect to policy uh particularly around
energy coming from Russia and also
divergences on in terms of what sort of
material support they can provide to
Ukraine but nonetheless even despite
small uh differences it was really
important for them last year and as
important for them this year to
communicate unequivocally that they are
in this together with Ukraine in support
of Ukraine right so do you expect that
any significant breakthroughs
well I think if uh if the Ukrainian
president does in fact uh come here it
is going to be an incredible opportunity
uh particularly for him in rallying
others to to the cause and most notably
particularly if he comes on Sunday this
is when the Indian Prime Minister
Narendra Modi is going to be here and of
course Modi over the past year well over
uh well over a year now has maintained
an
ambivalent position with respect to
Russia uh not outright uh condemning
them indeed very recently affirming the
friendship with Russia as being
unbreakable this is an opportunity for
zielinski himself this is an opportunity
for the G7 to try to bring Modi into the
fold and change his and his country's
position and what about sort of other
other items on the agenda because we
understand that China might be a talking
point as well do you expect any um what
do you expect to happen when it comes to
China
uh China will unquestionably be much
like Russia the the other big elephant
not in the room and and uh the
geopolitics surrounding China are also
at the top of everybody's Minds here
particularly with respect to Taiwan and
you know this is one of the things
that's particularly particularly
significant about Japan hosting this uh
this time around in that they are very
much taking the lead certainly as the
the regional actor
um of significance here in crafting G7
policy with respect to China and
particularly with respect to China and
Taiwan so I think we can see I expect to
see in the communique an awful lot of
language
um directed squarely at China right and
when you look at Japan's role in
particular when it comes to the G7
meeting I mean what what's your analysis
of Japan's foreign policy and the
direction that it's taking you were
talking about the direction just a
moment ago and also the fact that it's
being hosted in Hiroshima yeah
well one of the things that I think is
really really fascinating about Japanese
foreign policy right now is I I'm fairly
certain and very confident in saying
that we're very much at an inflection
point uh Japan has uh committed to
increasing defense spending uh in an
order of magnitude that has not been
seen since the end of the second World
War uh the uh Japanese have begun uh
increasing the posture of of their
military one of the things that I think
is quite significant is that the British
prime minister and the Japanese prime
minister when they met yesterday they
met on Japan's aircraft light aircraft
uh carrier that is of symbolic
significance I think what we're about to
see is in the in the coming years is a
far more
productive Japan in the world and more
active in the security sphere all right
we'll leave it there Thank You Tristan
Naylor thanks for speaking to us from
Japan
now speaking of China